[Music]
with drivers facing sticker shock right
now we wanted to take a closer look at
how u.s oil production relates to
soaring gas prices
aaa says the national average for a
gallon of gas is now four dollars and 24
cents but the price of crude oil is much
more important to oil producers this
morning the benchmark price is over 115
dollars a barrel a lot higher than last
year omar via franco went to oklahoma to
show the impact of oil prices on local
operators and the people who depend on
them
okay that's carol's house
is that how you identify things oh yeah
hidden between the barns and buried
three thousand feet underground is
darlene wallace's fortune
wallace operates 13 small oil wells near
seminole oklahoma known as stripper
wells producing up to 15 barrels a day
for columbus oil company
there are about 400 000 operational
stripper wells in the united states it's
not a high producing well it's not a
gusher well that's why they call them
stripper whales because we are stripping
the last bit of oil out of the well that
we can possibly get anything under 50 a
barrel we lose money superintendent tim
poplin showed us a sample of what they
collect this is the salt water
and this is
wilcox oil
and if you look it's really not all the
way across the top as long as oil is
over 50 a barrel it's worth doing the
work for yes yes oil prices have been
especially volatile in the last five
years and the boom and bust of the oil
patch can have a major impact on small
producers like columbus oil all of our
wells shut down when it went to a minus
number in april and we shut everything
down because you can't pay someone to
come
pick up your oil you had to shut down
for two months yeah what was that like
it was like not getting paycheck now
that number has reached about 115
dollars a barrel a pain at the pump for
the consumer but a boom for her small
business this is my rainy day fund so
i'm going to bank money and wait for
that crash to come because it will come
this business is very cyclic even though
it's maybe 10 to 15 barrels a day do you
think you guys can help the american
economy when it comes to oil and the oil
supply well we produce 10 percent of the
american oil that's what we you know
that's what stripper whales do it takes
mobilization ed hurst an energy fellow
at the university of houston says even
though oil is in a boom it's not easy to
just turn on the pumps
it can take months to get them online
and the workforce while rebounding has
taken a beating
in the last 10 years the sector has lost
more than 50 000 employees so when
people are saying you know we have
enough domestic supply
to bring out of the ground
and alleviate the pain at the pump is
that true oh that's absolutely true it
just requires capital our wells are not
the most productive in the world our
wells are the most expensive oil wells
in the world to drill because we don't
get the the huge output that say a saudi
well does
it's just a matter of dollars and cents
and no one's going to start drilling
unless they can see a path forward to
getting revenue and profits oil had gone
wallace won't slow down and plans to
keep pushing production of her small
wells whales are in the rural area
they're not in urban areas
and we give people in rural areas jobs
we can't let our rural areas
dissipate because there are no jobs
she says it may not help wall street but
it helps main street for cbs mornings
omar villafranca seminole oklahoma